fortunately the smell was so bad that I
ended up throwing up inside the trash
man about three times we're just
thinking I've seen in the trash is
another company came to our yard and
dropped off a bunch of pallets and we
discovered that there was a litter of
kitty cats inside of one of those
pallets so what we did is just stick
them to a local shelter and hopefully
they get adopted most of the trash goes
to our two local facilities which get
separate from canning glass the rest of
the garbage goes to the local landfill
we recycle about 80 percent of the
cartridge but the best thing for us is
to train our customers and educate them
on what should be recycled what do I
wish people stopped putting the trash
liquids liquids is one of the things
that makes our garbage very heavy right
now we're gonna head into our summertime
which will be a lot of barbecue coals
which you could become a hazardous fire
to us so if you have any questions is
always good to go to the local web site
and check what materials we should be
putting in the dumpster
does it bother me if someone calls me a
trash man instead of engineers no it
doesn't
unfortunately the general public does
not know what its sanitation engineer is
at the moment
so the garbage guy is not bad for them
most people just think that we just go
there to pick up the garbage and that's
it you'll be really surprised that most
of the people that work for us are very
friendly very polite and they're out
there to do a service for us and they're
making sure that not only is the streets
and the garbage in the areas clean for
everybody lizard for ourselves too and
make sure that you take care of the
environment you could tell a lot about a
person obviously their age what products
they use on a daily basis if they're
procrastinators we see people running
out behind us with their bins because
they forgot to take on the date the
night before I won't mention what kind
of food it was but I went to a local
restaurant that we were servicing
unfortunately the smell was so bad that
I ended up throwing up inside the trash
man about three times and at the end of
day is try to complete the job it
doesn't happen often but it was
summertime so obviously thinking about a
little quicker one of the best days of
the job for me
one day we had a customer that called us
that we lost a leather money bag before
chill we found it it contained about
twenty thousand dollars happy day for
him we found it and we gave it back to
him what should people think twice about
throwing away things that could be
donated like sofas clothes toys there's
a lot of people that out there that can
use them so it'd be nice if they could
be donated to the local shelter or a
thrift store it will benefit them more I
always think about what you can throw
away before you do there's a lot of
information on our website it's always
good to go and check it and verify it
before you throw something away canned
it could cause it in a real hazard to
someone else
[Music]